okay haha that is my new Shakira parody
song hey guys it is fried diary here on
its grace which means it's accumulation
of things I did throughout the week uh
first of all here's this I'm blogging
and vlogging yeah vlogging vlogging yeah
okay because we're shooting a very
top-secret project here at the YouTube
space it's got that it's here was here
so Oh wowie wow I was warm up the crowd
and then this thing shoot is continuing
I'd love to do something with mamrie she
has no idea she's in the back it's gonna
get weird don't forget about this fun
friend you guys I am currently headed to
memories house to meet beans for the
very first time if you who don't know
beans is maybe your dog it is a four
pound hairless creature I forget the
type of breed it is - wah-wah
and its tongue sticks out all the time
and I haven't met it yet and I'm just so
time
I'm gonna do so let's go what about this
oh my god I can't
cassis beans can't the world's greatest
dog / dear / bat / mouse you can lick
the camera
oh is that that's the Internet that's
the Internet oh yeah oh my god I'm
freaking sober then this happened and
now we're a rock stream go we are
assembling some special care packages
for some very special people and it's
top secret but here's a sneak preview Oh
would you expect anything less we just
wrapped up from day of making all these
mobile blah words not happening right
now I'm tired I made all these lovely
care packages hung at all pretzels
pretzels diesels and Pretz Gil's time I
gotta get better and then memory left
Michael a gift on his desk it is a
plastic knife that she purchased at Rite
Aid with a note this is xoxo and that
guy my Kevin Pereira
podcast we just wrapped it so now I
realize I'm not gonna hi I can't hear
any of it I swept the podcast how do you
feel about it I feel like pointless stay
calm so if you happen to tune into this
thing grace you're awesome because you
saved me Kevin just basically made my
loss a sponsor yeah his first ever
sponsor ting I love you ting just know
that uh Kevin compared them to slavery
I didn't item I did not I said that they
were like they were they were the north
in Michael Harrison ting is like it's
you don't want those contracts are those
binds is gonna stop that
donation from happening anyway when this
is come out this is coming out this week
funny when is this coming out this is
coming out on Friday so set your alarm
clocks ask your series say your lark
packs from Monday o'clock set it for my
vehicle when it goes up you roll out of
bed yeah all right
yep wipe the dorito dust off of you yeah
get the bomb take a nice trip for three
and then load up an hour-long youtube
video because we know how to make
internet content what you guys is
attention spans are they love it but
they aren't they have all my favorite
things look at this meal hey friends
oh hey friends also this this is another
clip I've had to thump so much today
Oh
chews editing juice what about this now
I'm in a car I'm wearing the same shirt
I wore yesterday I'd smelled it and it
didn't smell that dirty but that is one
of my biggest and securities is having a
bad odor to my person so I think that's
I mean I have a tiny bottle of body
splash in my glove compartment
it's like break glass in case of
emergency
oh the glass got so broke so long
I literally saw one of the first things
I do when I come back are spare us all
the body splash this is a great tale of
struggle and success this is what the
Internet's for right pay do not forget
about the time I did this I like your
necklace
thank you and super sharp and painful
and then this oh hello I'm on set for a
BuzzFeed shoot right now we shot a video
and it's rap ha ha ha ha ha Rob it's
fake wine it's fake wine they can fake
wine
like and this is here and that's here
and there spoilers but the real spoiler
is um Carol I'm showing them your liquor
cabinet okay just because it's insane I
get this if I can get it look at is it
stuck because there's so much goodness
huh look at that what the actual [ __ ]
hello guys okay I changed my clothes
into an outfit I I don't really know
what's going on here but this this and
this and then what's what is that like
what's happening
I know disapproval I'm going over to
Hannah Hart's place right now because
she mamrie and I are about to go to our
first screening of Camp Takota with like
friends and family and some press maybe
I don't know but it's the first time
that anyone outside of our small bubble
of people that have worked on the film
have seen it and so we're going to hand
us to get a little liquored up before we
go watch ourselves in front of other
people
let's go also look at the raining in Los
Angeles Wow God must be watching Camp
Takota and just crying over how
beautiful it is
and then this glow we are now going to
our screening of our bio excited oh I'm
soon arrested Talk memory rarity ruin to
have this bathroom yeah more tonight
yeah oh thank you thank you sir
thank you for shedding light on this
issue yeah and we are of course taking
over there because we have an interview
grace Helbig how do you feel about
watching your movie play out for the
first time in an audience of peers very
nervous and um I'm worried about it
feeling very self-serving because I
don't like watching my own stuff in
front of friends question as someone who
records herself at edits world's face
every day tell me about how you would
feel self serving in a new way because I
don't actually see other people watching
my face I just put it out there like
yeah and then repress and very good of
repressing things this it's hard to
repress in the moment that's why her
shirts are never wrinkly always
specially lip-read yeah I wish double
ironed yeah alright we'll go there let
me okay I gotta two hairs by the end of
those oh my god I'm five okay
the create a peaceful and people am
power the the man behind group now on
YouTube West Coast yeah you are very
gangster as I was hoping yourself in
this
all right then go that was my weak pit
in our wrap-up please go to camp Takota
common pre-order the camp Takota film
we're just so goddamn proud of it and
happy about it
and we really want you to have it and
don't forget the tonight on its grace my
channel at 4:30 Pacific Standard Time we
are doing a live stream - I mean camp
Takota is coming out soon we went to a
last minute livestream six more days six
more face and okay where we just answer
your questions and talk to you about
camp Takota I don't know